I've eaten so many croissants while
making this I'm starting to sweat butter
I am butter butter is me and butter Am I
[Music]
[Music]
Bojan event Kiana and today I'll be
making a rainbow song I'm comfortable
making croissants I've made coloured
croissants pink ones before and now the
challenge is to make one with five
colors so I think we'll be fine okay to
begin I'm gonna make the dough it's very
simple and when I combine some milk in
the water so now I'm gonna add in some
flour there was so you don't scrape the
bulls how much shake the bowl
aggressively and then really simple
sugar some instant yeast salt and butter
little crumble here and there just like
kind of give it a head start on the
mixing so it makes us for about just one
minute
so it starts becoming a very loose dough
and I'll kick it up to level two to
really start the needing a little bit
whoa that is tight so what I want is to
take 25% of my dough or the color those
gonna be from my colored dough and then
with the plane I'm just gonna shape this
into a nice Bowl and cover it I'm just
gonna let it hang out for two hours now
I need to divide this into five
different parts so it's not gonna be
technically a full rainbow I don't even
know didn't I go is it what is indigo
time for some color so I'm gonna do
these one at a time just so I don't
accidentally mixed color first color is
going to be pink right now it's really
kind of like a marbled effect but once
it expands those colors will also help
blend together there's one it looks like
in those sci-fi films if you will go in
outer space and then become a contact
and then their whole piece
vini before the big turns with monsoon
when they have to call them so right now
I'm gonna make one more cross Sandow for
this batch I'm going to use a different
brand inside these ones are gonna be
neon colors see which one does better I
think a runny gel based color is kind of
the moneymaker
cuz that way you get the best of both
worlds you get a strong color like you
had a traditional gel but get the spread
ability of those more generic
watercolors I'm not good at that
that looks good great save my five neon
colors now let's see how these two
colors match up so far they actually
look pretty similar so far maleeni
towards the neon because these three
colors have such a big blue tone i don't
know how distinguished you're gonna be
where these three colors how different
undertone so it's more of a contrast so
you'll see about a rainbow design I'm
just going to cover them loosely so you
can rust and rise and get nice and puffy
in the meantime I can have a tea break
so I have the color dough's and they are
very squidgy so I'm gonna start with
very little flour for dusting and I'm
just gonna shape it with my hands into a
very tiny rectangle take a little bar of
soap I'm gonna put this aside while I do
the exact same thing to the plane down
I'm not trying to knead it any further
develop any more gluten right now I just
want to get into a nice shape so it's
easy to work with tomorrow so I'm gonna
do the exact same ain't - my neon color
does and then put everything in the
fridge then tomorrow that's when I'll
actually make the croissants so it is
day 2 of cross-hall making right now I'm
gonna begin laminating my dough to roll
I like just giving it a little press and
tap to help stretch it out evenly let me
get out my block of butter for the
butter
I want it chilled but not so cold where
it will break I like just to pinch my
seam together that way when I start
rolling my butter won't come spilling
out this
it's I'll probably go for like around
two feet long right now I'm gonna do a
double fold or known as a book fold this
dough has been hanging out on the
freezer for like ten minutes so now I'm
gonna roll it and fold it one more time
before I start adding in the color
Deeley shoulda started rolling the same
side up but I forgot so that is just
under 7 inches by 6 inches so I'm gonna
put this in the fridge for now and then
start working on that colored oh these
look like gemstones these are the
Infinity stones I have found them there
and the tasty kitchen so what needs to
happen here this needs to be on top of
that so for now I need to figure out how
to get these on and try to roll these
out let's see that could work
because it was a bit dry I'm gonna brush
it with water to get it to stick maybe I
can like wrap it around what is the
order there you go I don't know how I
feel about these colors by each other I
don't like the way they look well
they're on there what I'm gonna do is
roll this out and then start shaping
them into you know
to the croissant this is hard to like
roll each color same thickness but I'm
not as concerned with like the mixing
cuz that marbling is really really
minimal right now so I'm gonna cut them
into triangles
I'm gonna use my handy ruler for
guidance and use a piece of cutter this
is a cool tool it's not just good for
pizza so what I want to do is slightly
stretch down that point just so will
help me close that letter you can tack
it down if it makes it easier and then
I'm strolling keeping it quite tight
this looks knock you there so ugly
I'm gonna come back and do my neon ones
and hopefully they look more pleasing to
the eye
so for this one I'm gonna make a color
sheet I'm gonna shape these all into
little logs and lay out all the colors
and then kind of like roll it out the
goal is to make these five tiny pieces
of dough become one and a brush off the
side that's gonna sink so don't have
extra flour and just lay that right on
top curious if it's easier to roll
bellies side down cuz with the first one
these metal colors really got stretch on
I was losing my pink and purple so I'm
wondering if I roll it with a color down
if that'll help control the stretch
oh yeah that's so much more even now I
am going to cut them into the triangles
and then same thing I'm gonna roll them
when you're rolling you don't want to
crush them I just want it to be tight
it's still gentle you know what they
also look like yeah little spinny tops
so they have been baked
I have batch number one I have batch
number two with a batch one I can tell
even the middle layers there's some
breakage between the two colors which I
kind of expected surprisingly these
colors are a lot bolder but it's what's
on the inside that counts I'm gonna cut
one of each open and compare it so I can
decide which color I want to go ahead
with
haha but so interesting Li can see three
colors really why is that okay that
looks a lot better whatever color I have
on the outside isn't gonna show on the
inside well this is gonna be fun here we
are
kasam a game day three I am going to
make a brand new batch and so last time
I did five rows of color and then only
three made it inside so I'm gonna double
up my rows and then ideally everything
will make it inside what are the colors
of the rainbow I don't know I'm Google
but I'm just gonna add here let's say
three drops oh that is not a drop more
like this squidge last time I was
getting like old nouveau with my
coloring I just feel like going red
orange green blue violet seems bright
these jewel hang out in the fridge
overnight hopefully develop a little bit
more in color particularly our friends
blue green and purple and I'll see them
in the morning so today is day two of my
new batch till the dough does time is a
little bit more narrow just so I can
make my triangles a bit shorter the last
time I felt like they were getting a
little bit long so I want a shorter
croissant to roll up so yeah it's gonna
get going on laminating the key is keep
the butter from mixing with the dough
see you have layers butter mix no layer
no layer no croissant everyone fails to
get my colors what I'm gonna do this
time instead of like rolling them out as
whole strips I'm gonna take each one cut
it in half so I'm gonna start with my
wrath now I'm gonna do the exact same
thing for all the colors I have each
color divided into two parts now and I'm
going to build the rainbow once and then
build it again okay look at that I'm
telling you if this is not a guarantee
all the colors inside it's just not
possible I need to pinch II pinch to
bind them all together because it needs
to be one I'm just gonna
help smush them to gather this needs to
be one inch larger than my plain dough
that way it's not only covering the top
but around the sides as well they just
have to focus on rolling wider not
longer and all will be well
wait hold up they just roll this the
wrong way
holy bejesus it doesn't that I've earned
it but Alec says is not read forever so
they're all rolled and now they have to
do their thing and prove they've already
started proving and then I'll brush it
with eggs and pop them in the oven and
else we'll be ready
well they're not the best ones I've ever
made but one thing I can do with this
batch is figure out if I have more color
on the inside eh okay yeah yeah all the
colors are in there tomorrow I'll make
another batch take my time and do it
right and then they'll be doesn't so
another day another croissant
yesterday's batch wasn't the best I
think today is gonna be great
so when making croissants if I don't
keep everything nice and cold it'll
start proving the stage I really want
the dough to prove is after it is shaped
because it took time because they rolled
it the wrong way and I'm filming so you
have hot lights all over it it started
proving way quicker than I needed it to
so by the time they got in the oven they
kind of hit their peak so you didn't get
any bigger this croissant dough needs to
be short and white therefore I need to
make my color strips thin and long so
when I place it on top of my white dough
everything will match up fine and all of
you are cool that is dope in order to
not mess this up I want to make it wide
this way I'm just gonna give it a little
roll
have this homeboy and the Kona over here
everything seems to be behaving well
staying cold it's also earlier in the
day so everything is a lot cooler
nothing is proving right now this is my
rested chilled dough so then I can roll
it a little bit thinner without having
my butter sloshing around right now it's
a little bit stressed and in the real
world I'll let it rest in the fridge
your freezer for a half hour one hour we
need to get some shots done so I'm gonna
cut them a little bit wider than I
normally was ideally they'd be three
inches wide I'm gonna do four inches so
when they shrink they'll be at the
perfect size they're sticking around
three inches which is the gold number
and they are 12 inches long so yeah
size-wise they're looking good look how
cute they are it's time for all the
magic to happen I'm gonna cover it and
leave it at room temperature for a
couple hours if they feel like they're
not proving quick enough I can pop them
in the oven with some warm water in the
bottom and I'll help speed up that
proving process look at them
so fluffy it's incredible like what a
couple of hours can do so all I need to
do is egg wash them pop it in the oven
and then we have very bones yeah it
sucks away from the cool and then I can
I am quite content because they look
nice and they don't look like trash more
importantly because yesterday's likely
garbage time as I sucked it now do that
crunch
Halla colors gosh you feel like every
time I bake its exact same lesson
patience practice makes perfect kind of
oh is it and filming ruins cooking those
are just facts truth of tasty so cute I
really want to keep this money forever I
actually might
[Music]
you